in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Paul
and the Karen are with us hey guys how
are ya great name
welcome welcome good to have you great
to be here now where do you guys live
Cleveland Ohio fun and you came all the
way to Nashville
yes we did I love it I love it I love it
will congratulations good that have you
oh and you brought a bunch of people
with you brought the whole party here
I'm a party yep this is it right here
our legacy so who are they well we have
our five children and we have a
daughter-in-law our grandson two of them
are engaged so their fiance's just okay
all right it's a Nashville party I love
it so how much dad of YouTube paid off
three hundred and twenty four thousand
dollars my goodness how long did that
take six years and three months
was that your house and everything yes
yes I love it making what kind of money
during this time we probably started in
the low 90s and then went down to the
low 80s and back up to about a hundred
and seventeen I think last year very
cool what do you two do for a living
well that's that's the cool part of the
story one of the things that this was
able to do in addition to paying that
off we were able to Karen quit her job
that's why the income went down for a
while and she was able to go back to
school and she's now a kindergarten
teacher oh good for you guys so living
the dream then absolutely so baby step
six to six years which it usually takes
seven is the average so you did it
pretty quick what's your homework that
you paid off probably two to ten
something like that phenomenal very cool
so 324 includes more than the home oh
yeah oh yes nuts
okay let's dip it in there how old are
you two
fifty-eight perfect fifty-six very cool
good good very cool and a paid-for
house so tell me the story what happened
six years ago it was it was like being
at a hamster wheel
you know just we had our first mortgage
second mortgage on our home we had a
rental property first mortgage second
mortgage
be putting our groceries on credit cards
because we didn't have any money and it
was just it was stifling and suffocating
and just thinking this is what we have
to look forward to for the rest of our
lives
and you know raising these kids and not
being able to give them what our parents
gave us just was very disheartening yeah
it was and I was we hit I'd never early
and I was working down in Atlanta and
I'd go back to the hotel every night and
I heard this crazy southern guy in the
radio talking about you paid off how
much money I didn't even know your name
but I eventually heard the name and went
online and downloaded whatever free
podcasts we could and I brought him home
put him on CD and we listened I probably
had 30 of them and we just listened for
a couple weeks and and said you want to
start this and the steps seem so II the
next step getting done doesn't seem
achievable but every step seems very
achievable so saving $1,000 was we'd had
that lots of times by accident but never
on purpose that was our first step and
it just worked all the way up to the end
it took six years yeah to work all seven
baby steps
yeah are all six to get you to the
seventh you know very good very very
cool congratulations thank you so at
that point you guys had been married
20-something years probably right yes
and how long you been married now it'll
be 30 years this year okay have you ever
been debt-free since you've been married
never not even before that and now
you're 100% house and everything yeah
it's amazing
freeing it's awesome I there's no way to
describe it it's just it's indescribable
well congratulations you guys thank you
that's a long run but that's the run you
take to get the house and everything
paid off so when people find out you've
done this and they say what's the secret
how'd you get out of debt what do you
tell them this that the principles are
the secrets are well you can sell your
coin collection that you started when
you were 10 years old on your paper out
that's well that's one of the things but
the real secret is that it's not a
secret it's just
the steps are simple yes don't spend
more than you make don't borrow more
money no borrow any money I just think
you know it's important that we both
were on board at the same time and just
coming to the realization that and
you've said many many times is that this
is not ours all of this is not ours this
is a gift from God and we were not
honoring him by doing what we were doing
and so you know he's blessed us so
abundantly that I think in order for us
to pay him back this is what we need to
do and and you know just it's
strengthened our relationship it's
strengthened our family and our some of
our kids have gone through the program
they're debt-free as well so they watch
the old dogs learn a new trick oh
absolutely yes and they're and now
they're doing it yes that's cool that's
very good that's really the best reward
this is great this is fun and but that's
the really the legacy going on is the
best reward yeah that changes the family
tree right there the knowledge being
passed yeah way to go you guys you're
fun this is great I'm so proud you got
to feel great oh it's amazing and thank
you
I mean you are a life changer you are an
inspiration you know so thank you we're
honored to be part of the story but
we're glad you guys with a hero man way
to go you guys
absolutely well done all right Paul and
Karen Cleveland Ohio first time in 30
years of marriage completely debt-free
house and everything in their 50s three
hundred and twenty four thousand paid
off in six years making 90 then 80 now
making 117 count it down let's hear a
debt free scream
praise the Lord Jesus
that's how it happens I love it man
that's amazing well done well done well
done hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show I want to write a song I want
to own my own business I want to make
more money
those aren't goals those are wishes my
new year's resolution is to make more
money this year to wish